Hi, my name is Rafi Taherian.
I'm the Associate Vice President
of Yale Hospitality.
Let's talk about this great
alternative to your diet.
A plant forward diet
is a style of eating
that emphasizes and celebrates
minimally processed,
plant based food.
This diet consists of
The idea comes from
Mediterranean diets
where animal protein is
not at the center of the dish
but is instead used
as a flavor enhancer.
Unlike a vegeterian or
vegan diet, it doesn't
restrict your eating.
A vegeterian diet
completely elminates
meat, poultry, and fish
and a vegan diet
excludes all animal
products or byproducts.
A plant forward diet
thoughtfully refocuses the meal
on vegetables and fruits
without eliminating
animal products.
A plant forward diet is
better for the planet
and better for you.
Animal-based food
has a bigger carbon footprint
than plant-based food.
Plus, eating a
plant forward diet
has been shown to reduce the
risk of heart disease and
Type 2 diabetes.
If you're following a vegan or
vegeterian diet, good for you
just please don't rely heavily
on super processed
meat substitutes.
Number two is be adventurous
when it comes to food.
The majority of people on this
planet use fresh herbs, spice,
fermented food, and all sorts of
other cooking techniques
to create delicious,
healthy, and bold flavors.
Try it! You might like it!
Three, if you're moving
toward a plant forward diet
start with things that you know
you like to eat.
If it is not delicious to you,
you won't be able to
stick with it.
Remember, it's better for you
and better for the planet.